شرخ في العلاقات بين بوتين ونتنياهو كشفت
عنه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه في
اعقاب اتصال هاتفي بينهما للمره الاولى
منذ اسابيع بحسب الصحيفه تناقضت روايه
الطرفين في فحو المكالمه ففي حين قال
الكريملين ان الحديث ركز على الوضع
الانساني الكارثي في غزه خرج نتنياهو
ليقول انه اكد لبوتين عدم رضاه عن المواقف
التي تبنتها روسيا في مجلس الامن العلاقات
الثنائيه بين روسيا واسرائيل تمر بمنعطف
جديد على وقع الحرب في غزه اذ لم يهتف
الرئيس بوتين نتنياهو لتقديم العزاء على
قتلى السابع من اكتوبر الا بعد نحو عره
ايام خطوه وصفت بالمتاح جدا مقارنه بقاده
الدول الغربيه واعقب بتها خطوات اخرى كانت
كفيله بازعاج تل ابيب واهمها استخدام
روسيا مع بكين حق نقد الفيتو في مجلس
الامن لمشروع قرار يدعو الى هدنه انسانيه
في غزه ويدين حماس وهو ما دفع اصواتا
اسرائيليه الى الدعوه الى التعامل مع
روسيا كخصم وتوحيد المواقف مع الغرب في
حرب اوكرانيا والبدء في تقديم اسلحه الى
كيب العلاقات بين الطرفين كانت متقلبه في
كثير من الاحيان فبعد حرب يونيو
1967 قطع موسكو علاقتها مع اسرائيل ولم
تعد العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بينهما الا
نهايه عام
1991 ثم شهدت العلاقات تحولا جذريا مع
تولي بوتين السلطه عام
[موسيقى]
1999 اذ تحولت من العداء المفتوح والحرب
بالوكاله في العهد السوفيتي الى بناء
علاقه تعاون تعمل على تجزئه نقاط الاحتكاك
وتجنب تجاوز الخطوط حمر لكن مع اندلاع
الحرب في اوكرانيا في فبراير شباط
2022 بدات العلاقات تاخذ مره جديده منحى
اخر في البدايه زار رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي انذاك نفتل بنيت موسكو في
الشهر التالي بذري العمل من اجل انهاء
الحرب في محاوله منه للحفاظ على علاقات
بلاده مع روسيا عبر لعب دور الوساطه دون
الاضراب بعلاقتها مع امريكا والغرب لكن
هذا التوجه تغير مع تعمق العلاقات الروسيه
الايرانيه وصفت اسرائيل على اثره ما
ترتكبه روسيا في اوكرانيا بجرائم الحرب
وردت روسيا على الاتهامات الاسرائيليه
بانها محاوله لاستغلال الوضع في اوكرانيا
لصرف انظار المجتمع الدولي عن معاناه اكثر
من مليونين ونصف المليون فلسطيني يعيشون
في الضفه الغربيه وتحويل قطاع غزه الى سجن
مفتوح منذ 14 عاما في ظل العلاقات
المتارجح ما مستقبل العلاقات الثنائيه بين
موسكو وتل
[موسيقى]
ابيب